I'll look who called in Ross Tucker
fill-in host of the Dan Patrick show
former NFL lineman the Ross Tucker
podcast and Ross you were your own does
social media last night with the hit on
Odell Beckham jr. where do you stand on
that hit by the way thanks for joining
us
yeah no problem then I just and maybe
this is just kind of the way I played an
but I'm not a big believer in anything
being cheap or dirty if it's legal like
I mean if it's that bad if it's that
cheap or that dirty then they should
make it illegal they have a new video
that comes out every year they have new
rules that come out every year new
points of emphasis but I don't know man
when I was out there Dan inside the
white line if it was legal I was doing
it but you have linemen when they're
engaged and you can't you can't go at
them right right but that's it but
that's a rule now you know when I was
playing on the backside of a running
play you actually were able to go low
you know which is what Denver did for
all those years as part of the reason
why Fruities guy Terrell Davis had so
many yards they were they were cutting
guys on the backside I also you know I
saw several people I won't say their
names but saying how could you do this
in a preseason game and that really
drives me crazy
for two reasons there number one when
you're outside when you're in there
right you're not thinking well this is
regular season this is put you're just
playing you're thinking about that
because if you're thinking anything like
that then you will get hurt you better
go full-speed and even more to the point
I mean the poor kid that hit Odell
Beckham jr. body Calhoun I mean he's he
went to junior college then he went to
Minnesota got cut by the Jags last year
I mean he kind of makes you feel like
him people say this is the preseason and
you know this it for that kid that's not
the preseason last leg was the Superbowl
for that kid and his family and his
lights yeah he's playing against Odell
Beckham jr. I'm sure he told everybody
knows hey you know I'm going to be
covering him I don't think it was a
cheap shot
and I think it was a legal hit but
Pauly's brought this up normally when
you get a star who gets hurt
change rules if you hit Carson Palmer at
the knees or Tom Brady at the knees you
know we look to change it you know
Buster Posey with the the slide that
swiped slide that they had that took out
his leg and broke his leg
if Odell Beckham jr. gets hurt does the
NFL look at that play differently a
thousand percent and I think that they
already might Bend because here's what
I've been thinking about this morning
you know we already have four
quarterbacks you can't hit him in the
head or neck area and you can't hit them
forcefully at the knee or below so we've
already established for the quarterback
position that the target zone is
basically the thigh pads to the shoulder
pads for the defenseless receivers we
already have the neck and head area you
know I think they're going to look at
potentially penalizing low hits hits to
the knee or below of defenseless
receivers I think it's hard the other
thing people don't realize Dan like my
first couple years in FL every play such
a blur I didn't know if I blocked a guy
or not like it just happen so it's not
slow-mo HD camera super slow-mo on your
couch like it is a blur out there but I
do think a worthwhile conversation
coming out of last night is should the
NFL explore some type of penalty for
hits to the knee or below of defenseless
receivers because if opah Beckham jr.
blew out his ACL last night I guarantee
they'd be thinking about that and they
might start to talk about it even before
because now you got an antonio brown h
acre you guys are all making 16 70
million I mean okay I get 20 million a
year yeah can you judge intent not
really that that's the best question
I've heard anybody ask in a while
because I've always been on the mind set
of all of these things don't throw the
flag watch the video when you can really
slow it down and if it's egregious find
the crap out of the guy but don't
penalize you know they told
officials on all these things when in
doubt throw the flag better sex games
and sometimes it's just a shot right to
the chest or even like if you I watched
the video to play last night 20 times
the kid hit him in the you know just
above the knee but then some of the
force went into the knee I think it's
hard to judge in 10 I would say give the
guys that better for the doubt but if
it's a guy with a track record like a
perfect or an Adama can sue someone like
that but I think they have lost a
benefit out if it's a second-year kid
we're just trying to make the minimum
this year after he got cut last year and
I think you give that guy the better for
the doubt
Ross thanks for joining us we appreciate
it absolutely that anytime an answer on
soccer fill-in host on the program the
Ross Tucker podcast former NFL lineman
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience